was baumeister 1 den monatelanger
fleißarbeit aus stein heraus meißelten
schichtet ein 3d drucker heute in
wenigen tagen auf ein organ mentales
wunderwerk diese technologie auch
additive fertigung genannt lässt in
vielen produktionsbereichen massive
umweltzone ahnen bereits sind schon
funktionsfähige waffen gedruckt werden
aus kunststoff wie aus metall
der additive schiff druck erlaubt auch
ganze autos in einem durchgang zu
drucken
vorläufig noch ohne den motor
läuferisch hat barack obama prophezeit
3d druck werde die industrielle
produktion revolutionieren
es klingt wie ein heilsversprechen meist
riebold in zürich einer der vielen neuen
3d copyshops wir treffen den
wissenschaftsjournalisten marcel hänggi
einen spezialisten für technikgeschichte
und ihre gesellschaftliche bedeutung
testen wir den hyde gleichen und selber
aus posieren für ein 3d porträt das ist
momentan angesagt
ob eingescannt wie hier oder direkt am
computer entworfen
der drucker benötigt dreidimensionale
daten solche kann man auch online
downloaden für x1000 gegenstände
produzieren wir künftig alles was wir
brauchen selber mit einem 3d drucker zu
hause
der nüchterne fachmann relativiert doch
die professionelle 3d fertigung gut
längst besonders geeignet ist sie für
proto typen und modelle sowie
ersatzteile hier ein alter fenstergriff
punktgenau brennt ein laser metallpulver
schichtweise zu jeder beliebigen form
und sei sie noch so komplex
die zürcher eth experimentiert mit
gerüsten die alarmierung für den
betonbau ohne verschalung dienen sollen
so werden gewundene organische
gebäudeformen realisierbar und bereits
gibt's noch raffiniertere geräte die
mittels uv licht aus flüssigen
kunststoff x-beliebige objekte formen
können werden die herkömmlichen
technologien schon bald überflüssig
die technikgeschichte spricht dagegen
will mir ja dokumente elektronisch
verschicken
das kapital passiert mittlerweile
arbeitet unser 3d drucker im pulver
barth aus gips und keramik wachsen die
party figürchen schicht für schicht
geradezu spektakuläres geschieht an der
zürcher hochschule für angewandte
wissenschaften in wädenswil
sie ist weltspitze im bio printing im
aufbau von lebendem gewebe per 3d klug
hier werden menschliche muskelzellen in
eine trägerstruktur gedruckt und zu
muskelgewebe aufgebaut
die zocken den fasern erlauben
zielgenaue medikamententests ohne
tierversuche eine kleine revolution im
pharmabereich
andernorts werden bereits knorpel und
knochen gewebe für implantate gedruckt
in einigen jahren erhofft man sich
komplette nieren und lebern
doch die 3d euphorie hat auch
lächerliche seiten der
lebensmittelgruppe etwa ist bislang
nicht mehr als ein digital gesteuerter
sprits sack für convenience food guten
appetit
ebenso hapert es noch gewaltig bei
textilien material und tragekomfort
lassen eindeutig zu wünschen übrig
trotzdem viele gebrauchsgegenstände sind
einfach und bald von jedermann
herzustellen
enthusiasten verkünden das ende des
industriezeitalters wenn jedes
energieproduzent wird dann werde die
ganze struktur von produktion und
distribution hinfällig hier werden die
flach und wir sind alle ganz leer mit
dem land das ist so eine vision wo
erstaunlich beständige geschichte vom
computer und jetzt erwarteten sieg von
didier drogba ich denke es wird drei mal
wieder nötig also keine weltrevolution
aus dem 3d drucker aber mit sicherheit
revolutionäre verfahren große umwälzung
und neue produkte
und dazu ganz viele dinge die die welt
nicht braucht die aber viel freude macht